hey everyone and welcome to this video
on devops engineer salary by simply loan
in this video we'll walk you through the
different salary packages you can expect
in different job roles of a devops
engineer but before we begin if you
enjoy watching these videos and find
them interesting then subscribe to our
Channel because we bring the best videos
for you daily also hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
so without any further delay let's start
this video by understanding what devops
actually is in today's world businesses
seek new ways to meet changing customer
needs that's where devops comes in it
helps companies deliver better products
faster making customers happier and
boosting profits so if you want to be
ahead and join the tech Revolution
devops is the way to do it on that note
we present to you the postgraduate
program in devops by simply loan if you
are able to become a devops engineer and
Propel your career to new heights then
simply learns postgraduate program in
devops is undoubtedly the right choice
for you this comprehensive devops
training course will unlock your true
potential by providing you with a solid
foundation informalizing and documenting
development processes along with
creating a self-documenting system
the program will not show your expertise
in advanced tools like puppet salt stack
and ansible enabling you to achieve
self-governance and automated management
at scale upon successful completion you
will earn the coveted Caltech ctme post
graduate certificate a testament to your
expertise in the devops domain so join
our Vibrant Community of devops
professionals who have harnessed the
power of Simply loans post-graduate
program to accelerate their careers
check out the link mentioned in the
description box below and enroll now to
become a successful devops engineer
so let's move on and now we'll see the
roles and responsibilities and the
salary figures of an entry-level
mid-level and senior level devops
engineer so let's start with entry level
devops engineer at this stage you are
the newcomers to the world of devops
your role primarily involves assisting
the team in setting up and maintaining
systems you are learning the ropes of
the deployment process helping with
automation tasks and absorbing knowledge
like a sponge so think of yourself as
the foundation builders in terms of
responsibilities you will collaborate
closely with senior team members to
understand the systems and processes you
might assist in scripting and automation
tasks you'll contribute to monitoring
and troubleshooting efforts under
guidance and the last one is you are
expected to learn about various tools
and practices used in devop talking
about the salary figures of an entry
level devops engineer according to class
2 an entry-level devops engineer working
in the United States earns around 109
000 and 16 dollars per annum the same
entry level devops engineer in India
earns around 5 lakh nine thousand rupees
annually next up is made
as for the mid-level devops engineer you
are stepping into a more involved role
so here you are not just learning you
are implementing and managing so your
responsibility is include designing
implementing and maintaining CI CD
pipelines for efficient software
delivery collaborating with development
operations and testing teams to ensure
smooth workflows troubleshooting more
complex issues and actively
participating in problem solving
mentoring junior team members and
assisting in their growth evaluating and
introducing new tools and Technologies
to enhance the devops process talking
about the salary figures of a mid-level
devops engineer according to Glassdoor a
mid-level devops engineer working in
this United States earns around 123 and
519 dollars per EO the same mid-level
devops engineer in India earns around 10
lakh Rupees annually
finally let's talk about the experienced
or senior devops engineer Ur season
experts leading the way and making
strategic decision your responsibilities
Encompass overseeing the end-to-end
devops strategy ensuring alignment with
Business Schools
designing scalable and secure
infrastructure that support continuous
integration and delivery collaborating
across departments to bridge the gap
between development and operations
automating processes at an advanced
level focusing on optimization and
efficiency
mentoring and coaching team members and
driving a culture of continuous
Improvement talking about the salary
figures of a senior devops engineer
according to glasstow a senior devops
engineer working in the United States
earns a whooping salary of 178 362
dollars the same senior devops engineer
in India earns 18 lakh rupees annually
to sum it up as you progress from entry
level to mid-level and eventually to
experience devop engineer your roles and
responsibilities evolved significantly
each level presents unique challenges
and opportunities for growth all
contributing to your journey as a
successful devops professional so
excited about the opportunities devops
offers great now let's talk about the
skills you will need to become a
successful devops engineer
coding and scripting strong knowledge of
programming languages like python Ruby
or JavaScript and scripting skills are
essential for Automation and Tool
development
system administration familiarity with
Linux Unix and Windows systems including
configuration and troubleshooting cloud
computing Proficiency in Cloud platforms
like AWS Azure or Google Cloud to deploy
and manage applications in the cloud
containerization and orchestration
understanding container Technologies
like Docker and container orchestration
tools like kubernetes is a must
continuous integration or deployment
experience with CI CD tools such as
Jenkins gitlab Ci or Circle CI to
automate the development workflow
infrastructure as code knowledge of IAC
tools like terraform or ansible to
manage infrastructure programmatically
monitoring and logging familiarity with
monitoring tools like promptials grafana
and logging Solutions like elk stack
acquiring these skills will not only
make you a valuable devops engineer but
will also open doors to exciting job
opportunities so to enroll in the
postgraduate program in devops today
click the link mentioned in the
description box below don't miss this
fantastic opportunity to invest in your
future let's take a minute to hear it
out from all Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
career through a postgraduate program in
devops after cool
realized that devops and cloud computing
were emerging fluids and I got
interested in them after some research I
decided to pursue the postgraduate
program in devops with help of Simply
learn with Caltech ctm after completion
of course I cracked a job with a hike of
100 and I'm very happy with it I learned
to use different Tools in Cloud as well
as devops such as easy to instance ECS
container technology such as Docker
kubernetes keep learning keep investing
in yourself and keep up Skilling
so thank you so much for joining us
today to explore the world of devops and
the incredible career opportunities it
presents remember the tech industry is
evolving rapidly and devops is the key
to staying ahead in the game so don't
hesitate to embrace this exciting career
path if you found this video helpful
please give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to our channel for more exciting Tech
related content
if you have any questions or want to
share your thoughts drop a comment below
we'll see you next time until then keep
learning and stay tuned to Simply learn